Maria Ann Sherwood was born into a farming
family in England in 1799.
Because of her parents’ work, she became
interested in agriculture and began working
on the farm as well.
When she was just nineteen years old she married
a man named Thomas Smith, who was also a farm
labourer, and the pair managed a farm in Beckley
for the next nineteen years, beginning a family
of their own.
In 1838, government officials were recruiting
people from agricultural backgrounds who possessed
the skills desperately needed for farms in
Australia.
Along with several other families from the
area, the Smiths boarded the Lady Nugent and
arrived in Sydney on November 27, 1838.
Upon their arrival, Thomas was given a job
by Mr. Smart of Kissing Point, later to become
Ryde, and earned £5 per year as a farm labourer.
Like most people in the area, the Smiths honed
their skills as orchardists.
Fruit abounded in the district.
Between 1855 and 1856, the Smiths bought their
own lot of land and began their own orchard.
Maria Ann Smith enjoyed raising her own seedling
apples, just as many of her neighbours specialized
in other varieties of fruits.
There are several different accounts about
her discovery of her namesake apple, but the
most likely one comes from an article in Farmer
and Settler from 1924.
Herbert Rumsey, who published the article,
was also an orchardist in the area and interviewed
two other farmers who knew Granny Smith.
They said that in 1868, Maria Ann Smith, then
69 years old, found the seedling growing by
a creek on her property.
She believed that the seedling had grown from
French crab apples (it is now believed that
the apple is a cross between the Malus sylvestris,
or European Wild Apple, and the M. domestica,
or domestic apple).
Granny Smith began to cultivate this new apple
tree.
Yet another local, Edward Gallard, developed
a large crop of them from cuttings from the
first tree and continued to do so annually
until his death in 1914.
The apples became widely popular in Australia
and New Zealand.
Displayed at the Castle Hill Agricultural
and Horticultural Show in 1891, “Smith’s
seedling” won the prize for best cooking-apple.
In 1895, Granny Smith Apples were being produced
at the Government Experimental Station in
Bathurst, New South Wales on a large scale.
Soon after, they were included on the list
of fruits suitable for export put out by the
Department of Agriculture.
The apples were introduced to Great Britain
in 1935.
This particular apple is a relatively recent
addition to the United States, where it was
introduced in 1972 by Grady Auvil of the Auvil
Fruit Company.
Unfortunately, Granny Smith herself never
saw her apples gain commercial recognition.
She died in 1870, just two years after discovering
the apple seedling on her property.
The apples were sustained and
propagated by local orchardists until they
became well-known, but it is Granny Smith
who will be remembered as the woman who discovered
one of the most well-known green apples.